For over a 200 years,
the world has been set on fire by a
revolutionary message.
The message is that every individual
human being is a divine.
That all of us,
despite the constraints and humiliations
that's around us,
can share in a greater life and share
even in the attributes that we ascribe
to God.
Nevertheless,
the ordinary experience of human beings
remains an experience of belittlement.
This revolutionary message can only be
made real through a series of
transformations,
transformations in how we organize
society,
in how we live and in how we understand
the world.
It is not enough to innovate in our
politics.
We must also innovate in our basic ideas
about who we are unless we innovate in
these ideas as well as in the
arrangements of society.
We cannot turn the message of our
divinity into a real experience.
Uh,
and thus the need today for a spiritual
revolution as well as for a social
transformation.
The focus of my thinking expressed in
this book,
the religion of the future lies
precisely there in the relation between
the transformation of personal
experience and the reorganization of
social life.
All the major religions and philosophies
that have exerted the greatest influence
over the last 2000 years,
uh,
arose from a series of religious
revolutions that took place around 2000
years ago.
And these religions took three main
directions,
one direction,
one my call overcoming the world.
And,
uh,
an example is Buddhism and the
philosophies that prevailed in ancient
India.
But it is a position to also represented
in modern Western thought.
For example,
by Schopenhauer.
According to this view,
all the distinctions and changes that
surround us are illusory.
Our task,
if we are to escape from suffering,
is to communicate with the hidden and
unified being a and to escape this
nightmare of the apparent world.
A second orientation,
uh,
when my called the humanization of the
world.
And it's teaches us that in a
meaningless world we can create meaning.
We can open a clearing space,
a social order that bears the imprint of
our humanity.
And in particular we can do so by
creating a society that conforms to a
model of what we owe to one another by
virtue of occupying certain roles.
The most important example of this
position in the history of religion and
philosophy has been confucianism.
The third direction is the direction
that I called him.
This book,
the religion of the future,
the struggle with the world.
It tells us that there is a trajectory
of ascent by which through changes in
how we live and in how we organize
society,
we can rise to a greater life and share
and the attributes that we ascribe to
God.
Uh,
and thus this ascent requires a
struggle.
And so I call it the struggle with the
world.
Now,
this third direction has had two main
phases in history,
a sacred face and a profane face.
The sacred face is represented in the
Semitic monotheisms,
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam,
and the profane face in the political
projects of liberalism,
socialism,
and democracy.
And in the project of personal
liberation that has been represented by
romanticism,
both the original romantic movement and
the worldwide popular romantic culture.
The third direction teaches us that each
of us is bigger than he seems to be,
that each of us is called to share in
the greater life and to participate in
this divinity that we sometimes treat as
a separate entity.
They created the world and that
intervenes in history.
It is this third direction that has
exerted the greatest influence on
humanity over the last couple of
centuries in forming a series of
revolutionary projects in politics and
in culture that have set the whole world
on fire,
but all of these religions in each of
these three directions that I have just
described,
despite their amends differences,
share certain common characteristics.
One of these characteristics is that
they have represented,
as it were,
a kind of two sided ticket.
One side of the ticket is a license to
escape the world.
A second side of the ticket is an
invitation to change the world,
and this ambivalence has never been
fully resolved.
Another common characteristic of these
religions is that each of them in some
way,
denies or seeks to compensate for the
incorrigible flaws in the human
condition,
our mortality,
our groundlessness and rn insatiability.
Despite the fecundity of our experience,
despite this fundamental aspect of our
humanity,
which is that there is always more in us
than there is in all of the social and
conceptual worlds that we build and
inhabit.
We are all doomed to die.
We cannot look into the beginning and
end of time or understand the framework
of our existence.
Our presuppositions never reached rock
bottom.
The bottom is bottomless.
That's our groundlessness and all of us
human beings demand the unlimited from
the limited and project this demand for
the unlimited onto particular
inappropriate objects.
That's our insatiability.
All of these religions have attempted to
say that there is a solution and
antidote that we in fact will not die or
at least that there is some
compensation,
some compensation for these enigmas and
terrors of our existence and entirely
different moment in the history of
religion would begin if we accepted
these realities for what they are and no
longer attempted to deny them.
Given the enormous impact
of the third direction that I described,
the struggle with the world
on humanity over the last two centuries,
one my desk.
What is the core of its message and why
has this message been so seductive?
There are two ideas that that stand at
the center of this view of the world,
both on its religious side,
okay?
The Near Eastern religions of salvation,
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam.
And on it's profane side,
the projects of political and personal
liberation.
One set of ideas has to do with the
relation between the self and others.
The dominant view in the history of
world,
religion and philosophy and indeed in
modern academic moral philosophy is that
the fundamental problem of moral life is
selfishness.
And the solution to selfishness is a
principle of altruism.
Okay?
And this principle of altruism is to be
enforced by conformity to certain rules
that define our obligations to one
another.
And these rules are to be determined by
some conceptual method like cons,
categorical imperative,
or Bentham's calculus of the greatest
happiness for the greatest number.
There is an attitude connected to those
ideas.
The attitude is that we should try to
come to the end of our lives blameless
with clean hands,
having discharged our obligations to one
another on the green side of our book of
moral accounts.
Yeah,
but that is not the view that stands at
the core of the moral beliefs of this
third tradition
there.
The view is that the basic problem of
our moral experience is not selfishness,
but rather a contradiction in the
conditions of personality and in our
relations to other people.
We need the others,
we make ourselves into human beings only
through connection,
but every connection is a threat.
Every connection jeopardizes our
freedom,
our autonomy,
our self construction,
and thus all of our relations to the
others are shadowed by an inescapable
ambivalence.
Sartre says the others are hell
describing aphoristic Lee,
this one side of this ambivalence.
Okay,
so what is then the solution that that
that lies at the center of this idea?
The solution is radical love in the
circle of intimacy and then some form of
cooperation of free and equal
cooperation outside the circle of
intimacy.
But this practical solution,
if one can call it that depends on an
imaginative capability,
the capacity to imagine the others,
to imagine their otherness.
And that is then the,
the teaching,
the real teaching that lives at the,
at the center of this tradition
for the ancients and for most of the
world religions and philosophies,
the highest ideal was the ideal of an
impersonal and impersonal and detached
benevolence from,
from on high,
from a distance,
implying no,
no risk on the part of,
of the [inaudible] of the benevolent
person.
But here now comes a different
conception that this impersonal
altruism,
this gift of benevolence from on high is
in fact not the center of our moral
experience.
That the highest form of moral
experience is reconciliation's Ian with
the other on the basis of equality and
at the price of a heightened
vulnerability.
Now there's a second set of ideas at the
center of this tradition.
And the second set of ideas has to do
with the relation between the structures
of social life
and the human spirit.
Now,
what I mean by spirit is the aspect of
our humanity that has to do with our
excess over all the regimes that we
create and inhabit.
Now,
there are two distortions that have had
a long career,
uh,
in the history of religious and
philosophical thinking.
One distortion might be called the heck
Ganean heresy.
It's the idea that there is a definitive
structure towards which history is
evolving and which will be the final
home of the human spirit.
And the other heresy,
one might call the Sartrean heresy or
the romantic heresy or the
existentialist heresy,
and it was prefigured by the mystics
within Judaism,
Christianity and Islam.
According to this heresy,
every structure is death to the spirit.
So the routines of marriage by contrast
to romantic love or the bureaucratic
apparatus of the state in opposition to
the crowd in the streets,
we can't get rid of the structures
definitively,
but we can momentarily rebel against
them.
And these interludes of rebellion or
then the time when we become most fully
human.
So it is a kind of despair.
It is a failure of our hope of changing
the relation of structured to spirit.
Now these two sets of ideas about the
self and others and spirit and structure
have never been adequately developed,
much less fully realized in political
and personal practice in the history of
our civilization.
Okay.
Both the political doctrines and the
religious traditions have lived in
compromise with the existing forms of
social organization,
uh,
and with ethical attitudes that
contradict their impulse.
That is another reason for spiritual
revolution.
Now,
if we were to take these ideas
seriously,
if we were to push them to the hilt,
if we were to ask how we should live
under the light of these ideas,
we would come to a completely different
conception,
a completely different conception of art
situation in the world and of the way to
organize society.
We have in fact in the history of our
culture,
in the history of the culture that has
been shaped by this third tradition,
the tradition of the struggle with the
world.
Only two completely developed images of
how to live.
One is the image of the sacrificial
altruist
who devotes himself to the others.
Without experiencing any intimate risk
or jeopardy.
And the other is the image of the
romantic adventure
who experience life as a perpetual
trial.
Yeah.
In the effort to deepen and affirm his
subjectivity.
Neither of these images is adequate as a
conception of how to live.
And the,
the absence of an alternative view
demonstrates once again,
the need for religious revolution.
Now
one should begin by understanding the,
the points of departure and the,
the provocations for,
for such a,
such a spiritual change.
Yeah.
So one provocation
is the need no longer to deny the
incurable defects in the human,
our mortality,
our groundlessness and Dora
insatiability.
A second provocation is the importance
of not confusing our belittlement with
these in escapable defects in human
life,
we are belittled and humiliated all of
us in some way to some degree.
But this belittlement has a cure.
Unlike our mortality,
our groundlessness and our
insatiability.
The cure is for us to make ourselves
bigger,
to ascend to a higher life.
And that cure requires a reorientation
of the way we live and of the way in
which we organize society.
Okay.
And a third provocation to this
spiritual change,
uh,
is then the,
the,
the unwillingness to allow those ideas
about self and others and spirit and
structure to be compromised and
circumvented as they have been in the
history of our religions and of our
societies.
Okay.
Uh,
so what does this mean?
What does this mean by way of a moral
orientation and what does it mean by way
of a political project?
Okay.
Let me illustrate what it means by way
of a moral orientation.
Bye.
Okay.
Referring to
how each of us is to respond to one of
the characteristic incidents in every
human life.
Yeah.
As we grow older,
each of us a,
a shell of compromise and routine begins
to form around us.
The self becomes rigidified in the
character.
The ancient Greeks said,
but character is fate.
Character is the rigidified form of the
self.
And the marriage of the character with a
social circumstance to which we are
resigned then becomes a proxy for the
living self.
A mummy that begins to form around each
of us within which
each of us slowly dies.
Many small debts.
Uh,
what we must then do is to break the
mummy apart.
Okay.
Uh,
the bedroom live.
and to become more God likes so that we
can live.
We do not live to become more godlike.
We become more godlike to live.
And how were we to break the mummy
apart?
We cannot simply will ourselves
transformed,
but the will can project us into
situations in which we are unprotected,
in which we lose our habitual
protections in which we are forced to
become more vulnerable.
Okay.
And in this way,
uh,
awakened to,
to a greater life.
So the rebellion against mummification
is one of the many telling consequences
of such a reorientation to existence.
And what does it mean by way of a
political project?
Okay.
Uh,
for two centuries now,
ideological debate in the world has
taken the form of a contrast between
what you might call shallow or quality
and shallow freedom,
the major political forces in the world
except the established institutions.
And then we think that the conservatives
are those who within that institutional
framework give priority to freedom.
And the progressive's are leftists are
those who give priority to equality,
but it is shallow equality against
shallow freedom because it's based on
this acceptance of the established
framework.
Now supposedly imagine that we can begin
to change this framework to innovate in
the institutions that define the market
economy and democratic politics to
democratize the market economy and to
deepen democracy.
The method is the cumulative
institutional transformation of society
and what is the objective?
The objective is not equality of outcome
or circumstance.
The objective is a greater life for the
ordinary man or a woman.
That's I would say deep freedom.
Who then are the progressive or
revolutionaries today.
First,
they are those who refuse to take the
established institutional structure for
granted.
And second,
they are those who demand not simply to
sugarcoat those structures with some
compensatory redistribution,
but to bring the mass of ordinary men
and women to a greater of intensity of
capability and up scope so that they can
live eyes wide awake and share in these
attributes,
in these attributes of transcendence
that we ascribed to the divine.
And that then projects us into a world
of institutional proposals.
And institutional changes.